zone Europe sur sensation
liberté égalité obésité c'est le thème
de cette émission spéciale organisé au
Centre français de Berlin avec le
soutien du fond citoyen franco-allemand
en France comme en Allemagne près d'un
adulte sur deux se trouve en situation
de surpoids les personnes atteintes
d'obésité ou même seulement surpoids
sont souvent victimes de discrimination
de façon répétée que ce soit à l'école
au travail ou dans la rue parmi nos
invités aujourd'hui Bénédicte et Nice
cofondatrice de la start-up ben nous
Christophe le full chef pâtissier de la
maison des Cauterets en Suisse Sabine
dubencroft chef berlinoise Anne-Sophie
Joly présidente du Collectif National
des associations d'obèses et Magloire
delcrozvaro animateur et réalisateur
zone Europe
bonjour Anne-Sophie Joly bonjour vous
êtes la présidente du Collectif National
des associations d'obèses est-ce que la
grossophobie c'est partout pareil est-ce
que les personnes en surpoids sont
steamatisées de la même manière en
Europe en Allemagne qu'en France
alors il y a effectivement une forme de
discrimination en France qui est pas du
tout j'ai envie de vous dire officiel
c'est il y a bah oui il faut pas dire
machin faut pas faire et puis en fait
dans les faits c'est c'est fait c'est
dit donc
il y a ça on en Allemagne il y a
peut-être un petit peu plus
d'acceptation
parce que les mentalités sont un peu
différentes mais on reste quand même sur
un gros problème de ce que de dire de
grossophobie et de discrimination
quelques statistiques récentes près d'un
quart des adultes sont obèses en Europe
entre 5 à 9 ans un enfant sur 8 et obèse
est-ce que les autorités sont-elles trop
tarder à réagir
alors les autorités si on parle de la
France en fait
j'ai envie de vous dire qu'on parle de
d'autres pays européens la France est
quand même très active dans le sujet
même si à mes yeux il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup travaillent à faire
beaucoup de chemin à fréquenter mais le
en France on a cette chance d'avoir un
Plan National Nutrition Santé un PNLS
avec des projets hyper ambitieux et
hyper intéressant notamment dans le
pnns4 on a également eu donc le plan
obésité l'écriture de la feuille de
route obésité donc ils sont quand même
des projets j'ai envie de dire étatique
au sens large du terme là on en parlait
tout à l'heure sur la deuxième table
ronde sur finalement ce qui était fait
au niveau de l'alimentation mais ce que
les gens ne savent beaucoup moins c'est
qu'on a le CNA en France qui est le
Conseil national de l'alimentation qui
sous l'égide de 4 ministères qui
travaillent beaucoup sur ces questions
là à la fois de production alimentaire
de transformation alimentaire de
marketing
avec une partie écologique parce qu'il y
a le ministère de l'écologie qui est
dedans le ministère de l'Agriculture le
ministère de des finances et ministères
de la Santé on est très bien loti en
France on est très très bien loti il
faut aller évidemment beaucoup plus loin
et beaucoup plus vite c'est à dire nous
donner les moyens de faire encore plus
de choses parce qu'effectivement
l'obésité en France c'est 8 millions de
personnes surpoiles obésité c'est 33
millions de personnes qui effectivement
impact de plus en plus des enfants la
problématique des perspectives sur
l'Union européenne est catastrophique il
y a comme vous le dites il y a urgence
cruciale d'avancer d'avancer vite et
d'avancer bien avec les bonnes personnes
en France depuis quand est-ce qu'il y a
eu cette prise de conscience que depuis
quand est-ce qu'on parle d'obésité de
grossophobie qu'on met de des mots sur
finalement des termes que que certains
vivent au quotidien
alors je sincèrement je pense qu'on est
plusieurs
on est plusieurs à être dedans depuis
longtemps
nous modestement le collectif a fêté ses
20 ans en 2023 en mars 2023 moi ça fait
23 ans que je travaille sur la
problématique et c'est
on a vraiment avancé parce que on a rien
lâché pendant 23 ans en fait mais c'est
c'est une aventure humaine de plusieurs
personnes et puis c'est des gens qui
nous ont qui nous ont rejoints et qui
ont compris l'enjeu de la problématique
merci beaucoup Anne-Sophie Joly merci à
vous je rappelle que vous êtes la
présidente de l'association du collectif
national des associations
bonjour magouar bonjour vous êtes
animateur de télé de radio réalisateur
aussi vous avez
donc réalisé le film grossophobia
comment est-ce que on vit
lorsqu'on est donc victime de la cible
d'attaque grossophobe comment est-ce
qu'on le vit aujourd'hui et puis avant
aussi quand on était plus jeune c'est un
sentiment d'injustice
je peux être la cible de plusieurs
façons de plusieurs discriminations
possibles je suis noir homosexuel je
suis et je suis gros
comme le Laetitia Berlin je vais redire
ice been fête fête ça veut dire je suis
grand en allemand
mais
celle qui celle dont je suis le plus
souvent victime
c'est pas le fait que ce soit noir
c'est le fait que ce soit gros et je
trouve ça tout à fait incroyablement
injuste comme toutes les discriminations
parce que
elle fait référence à quelque chose que
de toute façon quelle que soit la
discrimination n'a jamais choisi
mais qui en plus part de l'état de santé
déréglé
et c'est incroyable qu'on puisse enfin
quand si on croise une cancéreux qui n'a
pas de cheveux on va pas lui dire
donc je pense qu'il y avait urgence à
prendre le combat donc comment je l'ai
pris pendant des années très mal et
aujourd'hui c'est un combat donc on se
bat et aujourd'hui donc dans ce combat
vous avez réalisé un court métrage pour
dénoncer la la grossophobie ça s'appelle
grossophobia un film écrit et interprété
par des jeunes de Tarnos dans les Landes
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus marqué en
préparant ce court-métrage et comment
est né cette idée c'est leur volonté
c'est la volonté de tous ces jeunes de
de le faire déjà de l'écrire de le jouer
de l'interpréter et qu'il existe ils
sont vraiment battus
je pense que sans eux je leur ai
évidemment jamais fait bien entendu on
aurait même pas eu l'idée on a fait une
photo pour inciter les obèses à venir à
la plage sur la merveilleuse plage de
Tarnos ça s'est transformé en un
court-métrage ils ont motivé mobilisé le
maire que je remercie le maire de
Tarnaud la CAF qui a donné des sous avec
quelques unités là-bas sur place le
Conseil Général pour utiliser les les
écoles ils se sont battus comme des fous
et donc moi j'ai eu une espèce de voir
royal ou d'un coup j'avais assez d'un
qui était prêt des lieux tournage défini
un casting de la fin
comment voulez-vous dire non j'ai dit
oui bien sûr avec plaisir et puis
surtout c'est l'histoire subjective une
petite fille qui deviendront dès qu'on
ne voit jamais savent à la fin et c'est
l'histoire vraie donc de de Mélissa que
l'on voit mais de Mélissa il a des
antennes moi aussi je Mélissa nous
sommes toutes des Mélissa c'est-à-dire
nous sommes tous atteint d'obésité
par vide qui nous empêche de regarder
dans un miroir qui nous empêche de nous
regarder dans un miroir je le répète
parce que je parle vite donc dans ce
film il y a plusieurs donc séquences de
la vie quotidienne ou donc une petite
fille est victime d'attaque grossophobe
est-ce que vous êtes aussi inspiré de
votre histoire personnelle est-ce que
c'est scène vous les avez également vécu
toutes les scènes que vous voyez dans ce
film sont toutes des scènes vécues par
l'un par l'autre ou toute vécu par tout
le monde
toi tu dois pas manger ça parce que tu
es trop gros je l'entends tous les jours
aujourd'hui
ce regard pleine commissération de vos
meilleurs amis qui vous disent non tu
devrais pas en prendre donc bah non mais
c'est pas mon médecin quoi pourquoi
justement dans l'obésité des gens qui
n'ont qu'une autorité à le faire font
des des réflexions où vous préconise va
vous prescrire sans être médecin
des solutions c'est ridicule
donc c'est toute cette alors que tu n'as
pas de bons sentiments parfois
gentil avec lui il va un coup pour être
méchant mais ça fait pour les enfants
qui le sont stigmatisés 80% des adultes
obèses sont des enfants qui étaient
maltraités par rapport à leur obésité
merci beaucoup ma grande d'avoir été
avec nous merci à vous deux parce que
vous êtes deux j'aimerais bien que la
caméra merci à Pierre à la technique je
rappelle que vous êtes réalisateur
animateur de télé radio et réalité
donc on met trois et bien on regardera
ça merci beaucoup ma gloire j'espère que
vous allez nous inviter
son Europe
bonjour Bénédicte tennis bonjour vous
êtes cofondatrice de la start-up Benou
sa situe en Allemagne donc pour mieux
manger c'est devenu une priorité aussi
ici alors oui mieux manger c'est devenu
une priorité les habitudes alimentaires
des consommateurs allemands sont de plus
en plus favorables enfin on s'aperçoit
que les consommateurs allemands sont de
plus en plus favorables à une plus
grande protection du climat à la
durabilité et à la réduction des déchets
et donc ça ça passe par une consommation
d'avantage de produits locaux et moines
racontez-nous maintenant un peu votre
parcours pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
lancé dans cette aventure ben nous alors
je suis arrivée en Allemagne en 2018 et
en même temps
ma co-fondatrice oriente arrivait
également avec sa famille donc nous
avons deux familles respectives et nous
étions à la recherche de produits de
bons produits de produits locaux et puis
on a commencé à se poser la question à
savoir est-ce qu'on peut consommer de
saison à Berlin toute l'année on s'est
aperçu que pour avoir une alimentation
bonne pour nous et pour la planète il
fallait essayer de faire de
l'alimentation locale et donc on s'est
lancé le challenge de faire ça sur un an
avec une trentaine de testeurs donc on a
créé des recettes avec des chefs on est
trouvé énormément de producteurs locaux
et puis on a on a fait testé toutes ces
recettes donc avec nos testeurs et
comment est-ce que vous travaillez
aujourd'hui quels sont les différents
produits que vous proposez avec Ben nous
aujourd'hui
donc on s'est aperçu que pour manger
plus local ça passait par par de
l'éducation il fallait vraiment faire un
changement dans les habitudes
alimentaires et donc éduquer aujourd'hui
on passe par des entreprises
pour laquelle on propose nos recettes à
des équipes donc des équipes cuisine
ensemble et puis ensuite partagent un
repas donc par la cuisine il y a des tas
de choses qui se passent et c'est très
émotionnel la cuisine et donc le ce
qu'on appelle en anglais le team
building c'est excellent de faire ça
autour de autour d'ateliers culinaires
on propose donc des produits de saison
donc en été on aura des tomates on aura
des concombres puisqu'on a besoin de
plus d'eau en hiver on aura des produits
qui seront plus chargés en minéraux donc
on aura des racines des choux et
finalement on s'aperçoit qu'il faut se
reconnecter au rythme des saisons donc
c'est bon pour notre corps et c'est bon
pour la santé et qu'est-ce que vos
clients recherchent mieux manger une
alimentation plus saine principalement
oui essentiellement une alimentation
plus saine mais également de la
transparence sur d'où viennent les
aliments
recherche également bien sûr des
aliments qui vont avoir moins d'impact
sur le sur le climat donc une de créer
un repas ou une assiette qui soit qui
qui a un faible impact sur le sur
l'environnement voilà les principales
raisons pour lesquelles nos clients ne
choisissent et bien merci beaucoup
Bénédicte d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup je rappelle que vous êtes la
co-fondatrice de la start-up Binou à
Berlin merci au revoir
Christophe level bonjour vous êtes
originaire de Wissembourg dans le bar
vous avez grandi à la frontière entre la
France et l'Allemagne vous êtes
aujourd'hui chef pâtissier en Suisse
vous avez été nommé chef pâtissier
suisse de l'année en 2021 par le célèbre
guide got et Millau alors est-ce que
Christophe tous les desserts et les
gâteaux sont-ils font-ils grossir
avant moi les gâteaux ne font pas
forcément grossir je pense que
forcément il y a des gâteaux qui vont
être un peu plus graves d'autres ça
c'est sûr mais je pense que c'est pas ça
qui va faire en sorte que ça fait
vraiment grossir je pense que c'est
vraiment ça fait vraiment partie de
d'une consommation excessive où on peut
dire que ça peut peut-être faire grossir
mais si on reste raisonnable et que
c'est du plaisir je pense pas que ce
soit est-ce que aujourd'hui quand un
pâtissier d'abord c'est dessert il pense
aussi à l'aspect calorique et pas
uniquement à l'aspect goût texture au
visuel alors c'est pas vraiment le
travail d'un pâtissier de penser
calories entre guillemets on est là pour
pour créer donner du plaisir et puis
créer justement des nouvelles des
nouvelles choses c'est sûr qu'on peut
réfléchir à comment ça fonctionne mais
après voilà un diététicien est beaucoup
plus amené à faire ça en terme de de
temps on est assez limité donc je pense
que c'est pas vraiment à nous de le
faire
est-ce qu'il y a une évolution aussi en
matière d'offre en termes de dessert on
a l'image dans certains pays il y a des
gâteaux beaucoup plus gros par exemple
je pense que l'offre elle évolue avec la
mode avec la société voilà c'est un peu
comme la mode ça veut dire que
maintenant on est on est sur des gâteaux
qui vont être beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus léger mais parce que les recettes
évoluent aussi mais c'est rosette des
évoluent parce que il y a certains chefs
qui vont amener justement des choses
nouvelles ou des techniques nouvelles
qui vont faire en sorte que ce soit
justement plus léger mais on va dire que
sinon je dirais la tendance actuelle ce
serait de revenir au classique de la
pâtisserie mais en étant beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus précis on est vraiment sur
la précision en ce moment pendant très
longtemps c'est le gras qui a été
l'ennemi l'ennemi maintenant c'est
souvent le sucre pour son côté addictif
et parce qu'il favorise donc la prise de
poids et peut provoquer du diabète des
maladies cardio-vasculaires également et
même un vieillissement prématuré les
dosages de sucre est-ce qu'ils ont
changé ces dernières années alors oui
forcément les dosages ils ont changé
j'ai bien vu aussi maintenant par
rapport aux recettes qu'on faisait avant
même moi des fois j'y travaille encore à
dire ok bah je vais encore réduire le
sucre dans certaines recettes par contre
faut pas l'oublier c'est aussi un
exhausteur de goût donc c'est quelque
chose qui est fait aussi que ça donne du
goût un produit comme le sel je pense
qu'il faut avoir faut être assez
raisonné il y a eu une grosse bataille
sur le sucre ces dernières années même à
beaucoup à Paris avec les médias avec
beaucoup de chef assis et qui
travaillent sans sucre mais au final on
travaillera toujours du sucre parce
qu'il y en a dans les fruits il y en a
il y en a dans le miel il y en a dans le
chocolat donc c'est un peu complexe de
pour moi de dire je travaille sans sucre
parce que c'est un peu c'est un peu un
faux message parce que pour moi c'est
c'est pas là où on doit travailler merci
beaucoup Christophe Lefel d'avoir été
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
chef pâtissier ensuite
bonjour Sabine du bencroft vous êtes
chef cuisinière ici en Allemagne vous
avez assisté à la table ronde liberté
égalité obésité aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que vous en avez pensé d'abord
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé ça très intéressant la
discussion et les courts métrages moi
l'image qui m'a été transmise par mes
parents c'est que j'étais pas forcément
la plus fête de toutes et encore
aujourd'hui je pense que je fais partie
des femmes un peu plus grandes et je
trouve que c'est vraiment très
intéressant de voir qu'il y a une autre
approche en France j'ai pas tout à fait
compris si c'est une association ou si
c'est le gouvernement vraiment qui
décide d'agir à un autre niveau mais je
trouve que c'est important de
sensibiliser à la thématique et par
exemple la situation qu'on a vu chez le
médecin ou en effet si on a intérêt
réagissait tous avec un peu plus de
bienveillance ça se passerait mieux pour
tout le monde comment ça se passe ici en
Allemagne justement c'est intéressant
d'avoir le point de vue allemand est-ce
que il y a de la prévention qui qui est
faite est-ce que les personnes qui sont
donc victimes de grossophobie sont plus
acceptés dans la société où il y a
encore énormément d'efforts à faire ici
aussi de ce côté de ce côté si dur
mais tu peux donner une vidéo Center
hutchland a aussi du stand prevention
Butterfield
deutschland discriminium
programme
[Musique]
je suis pas tout à fait sûre de
pouvoir répondre à la question dans le
sens où j'ai pas connaissance de
programme de prévention de
sensibilisation à ma connaissance en
n'existe pas moi la façon dont j'ai
grandi c'est que chacun chacune avait le
droit d'être qui veut d'exister tel
qu'il existe et donc personnellement
j'ai malheureusement rarement vécu ce
genre de moments de discrimination donc
je peux pas vraiment répondre à la
question
mais à ma connaissance il y a pas de
programme spécifique qui ont vraiment
pour cible cette thématique là de
l'obésité et on est plutôt dans la
prévention qui vise à sensibiliser à
cette idée que chacun chacune peut être
comme il veut
pour finir sa ville du bref 9 vous avez
donc présenté à la suite de la Table
Ronde une recette est-ce que vous pouvez
nous la présenter et nous dire un petit
peu les différentes étapes de la recette
caution
raviolis
[Musique]
donc ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui ce sont
des raviolis avec du potiron et une
sauce de blettes au yaourt et je pense
que ce qu'on a vraiment oublié c'est
comment cuisiner avec des produits de
saison et des produits locaux parce
qu'on manque d'inspiration et mon
objectif aujourd'hui c'était de montrer
qu'il est possible de cuisiner régional
et de saison et en peu de temps donc par
exemple de montrer quand l'espace de 2
minutes je peux faire des de la pâte
pour des raviolis et qu'en 30 minutes
j'ai cuisiné un plat sain régional
équilibré et rapide à faire merci
beaucoup Sabine d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes chef cuisinière
ici à Berlin et merci beaucoup Anna
Johansson notre interprète aujourd'hui
zone Europe sur sensation avec le
soutien financier du fond citoyen
franco-al